hey youtubers its charlie happy holidays
hopefully you guys have been having an
awesome weekend so far I thought I'd
dedicate a Captain America Civil War
video to all the people that are missing
from the trailer or at least the biggest
ones what I'm gonna do is play the
trailer one more time watch it and then
let me know in the comments like the
biggest characters that you know are in
the movie or you're pretty sure in the
movie but don't see in the trailer
already a couple of you are like writing
the ones that I put in the title of the
video so here we go buck do you remember
me your mom's name is Sarah he used to
wear newspapers in your shoes you're a
wanted man I don't do that anymore
well the people who think you did are
coming right now they're not planning on
taking you alive
Jeff done well a great many people see
you as a hero there are some would
prefer the word vigilante they've
operated with unlimited power and no
supervision that's something the world
can no longer tolerate
I know how much Bucky means you stay out
of this one
please you only make this worse you
saying you'll arrest me
there will be consequences captain you
seem a little defensive buzz been a long
day if you can't accept limitations
we're no better new bad guys that's not
the last
so simply want to punch you in your
perfect teeth
I just want to make sure we consider all
our options
just people that shoot at you usually
wound up shooting at me too
you know what's about to happen
do you really want to punch your way out
of this
what do we do who fight
sorry Tommy you know I wouldn't do this
if I had any other choice but he's my
friend
so was I
so biggest characters that are missing
ant-man spider-man and the vision we
know that ant-man is in the movie
because in the phase 2 DVD set there's a
Captain America Civil War scene from the
ant-man movie is like a behind the
scenes thing where Paul Rudd's character
where Scott Lang gets to meet Steve
Rogers totally fangirls on him does the
Peggy Carter thing where she like
reaches out and touches his pic like
right after he comes out after getting
juiced up as Captain America and even if
you don't have the DVD set or you didn't
see that promo you probably saw the
post-credits scene with the Captain
America Civil War seat where Falcons
like I know a guy they I mean they even
put it in the trailer he's talking about
Scott Lang so why didn't they put
ant-man in the Captain America civil war
trailer he's a pretty big character they
just they just did a movie for him well
my thought is is because he probably
comes in late in the game like they need
him to get someone or something from
inside the New Avengers facility he
broke in once he can break in again
those were some of the best moments from
the ant-man movie where he went up
against Anthony Mackie sorry about this
dude but I got to steal something from
the Avengers big fan by the way
and it's not super important from this
video but a lot of you been asking you
about the toy set with Giant Man yeah
he's definitely gonna be giant man in
the movie so you know big ant-man stuff
happening in Captain America Civil War
even though he's not necessarily the
biggest character in the movie teamcap
all the way
what about vision though he's supposed
to be in the movie too he's supposed to
be team Iron Man for that matter because
Scarlet Witch is gonna be team cap so
it's gonna be nice to see them go at
each other my guess is is that visions
not a trailer because he's also a much
smaller part of the movie and he would
probably overpower the trailer people go
crazy when any of the Avengers are in a
trailer but the problem is that vision
has the mind gem which makes him like a
super Avenger so he probably start
pulling attention away from the fact
that this is a Captain America movie
it's centered around him and it's mostly
about his conflict with Iron Man and
like the division in the Avengers but
the last big guy what about spider-man
the New Avengers facility is in upstate
New York that's nowhere close to New
York City there's a pretty far drive
from the city
spider-man is much more likely to run
into Luke Cage at Harlem or Jessica
Jones or daredevil in Hell's Kitchen but
just because they have the new Avengers
facility doesn't mean that they don't
have the Avengers Tower anymore it's at
some point Tony Stark is gonna rebuild
that so they still have a base of
operations in New York City and that's
probably gonna be where they'll run into
him it's not like spider-man is gonna be
on his summer vacation in upstate New
York and just accidentally happened upon
the New Avengers facility like there has
to be a reason for him to run into Iron
Man and Captain America but the biggest
reason why he's not in this trail I know
a lot of people were like how come he's
not in the trailer he's like the biggest
thing in the movie that we're excited
about everyone's freaking out well
actually at least at this point right
now it's a really simple reason I mean
they could always choose to keep him out
of all the trailers as we get closer to
the movie it's still a ways off but
right now they're still making the CG
for his suit his suit is not done yet so
he they can't put him in the trailer and
they're not gonna put him in the trailer
if he's not gonna be in the suit like if
they want you to get hype about
spider-man they're gonna give you
spider-man they won't give you Peter
Parker
they'll be like BAM here he is in this
suit everybody poop your pants you're
welcome now they could always choose to
do the thing that they did with the
vision in the Avengers age of Ultron
trailers they waited till like the third
trailer it was like four weeks before
the movie came out so Captain America
Civil War not coming till May so we
might see spider-man in April but you
never know he's gonna be big in the
movie but but his part is not as big as
say like Black Panthers part and for
those who use that are asking like you
know if spider-man is gonna cameo in the
Avengers franchises the does that mean
Avengers are gonna cameo in spider-man's
franchise there is the rumor like I
actually kind of believe the rumor is
fairly plausible that there will be a
couple of Avengers appearing briefly in
the very first spider-man standalone
film at Sony and the really awesome
thing about that is we don't actually
have to wait that long before that movie
comes it's gonna be coming the year
after Captain America Civil War so in
less than two years you'll get to see a
rebooted spider-man universe under
Marvel's watchful eye seriously Sony
still owns the character it's gonna be
their new trilogy but they are in
creative partnership with Marvel as they
make these new films one of the
complaints I don't know that it was
necessarily a complaint but it was it
kind of like a subtle tick that Brian
Michael Bendis gave against like former
Sony executives because all these big
movies are made by committees obviously
the spider-man movies are made by
committee which is always a terrible
idea but he said he would be brought in
to advise I think the only thing that he
said that he gave them advice on that
they actually used was the mechanical
web-shooters in amazing spider-man so
don't worry when January comes there's
actually going to be like a special
Captain America
fifth anniversary special they'll
probably drop a new trailer whenever
that happens I'll totally do video for
it and I'll keep you guys posted like on
when stuff is happening agent Carter
season 2 is starting around the same
time that flash and arrow come back and
legends of tomorrow starts so there's
gonna be a [ __ ] ton of superhero stuff
happening at the end of January so be
sure to subscribe to get everything if
there's any bonus videos that you guys
want for Avengers characters or Captain
America Civil War characters just let me
know in the comments so while you guys
wait for everything to post you can
click here for all my Captain America
Civil War videos and you can click here
to watch the Deadpool red band trailer
again thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you